but scoliosis did not exist in my
neighborhood because we played buck buck
and the girls played too so somebody
grabs on a wall whatever they bend over
you're standing up you're not you're
bent in the 90s I'm the pillow and then
you connect like a centipede with my
neck and we all connect like centipedes
and then somebody Sprints from back 30
yards Sprints and leaps on your spine
and you're supposed to try to hold
you're holding on then there's a count
off
ten nine eight and that's when you have
to try to break them and then we kept
doing it over but what if the line
doesn't break what is that now it's that
turn oh they get the uh they're walking
away from you with their hair mask
bleeding now it's our turn
it's tremendous but I remember